dylan what is going on my man
john running the show yeah let's go how
are you doing
doing good man doing good bitcoins
pumping how what is your uh what is your
settlement about the market right now
how are you feeling about bitcoin kind
of increasing having that giant increase
yesterday
i mean it was definitely a massive short
squeeze uh it was it was something that
i think a lot of people weren't
expecting
i was kind of shocked just at the
magnitude of it but
uh definitely not something on a medium
term long term time horizon that that is
shocking at all i mean we talk about uh
you know coming down here every every
tuesday and talking talking the market
and talking about a potential decoupling
happening i mean that's you know these
days like we had yesterday uh that's
that's kind of what we're looking at
right like equities down kind of
chopping around bitcoin up 15 16 has a
lot of sideline cash and and managers
all over the world are watching uh it
was definitely something to behold
nice nice and then uh we have some
charts from you that i'd love to get to
um your first chart is talking about the
us treasury bond yields can you talk
about what this chart means
yeah so um over the last couple couple
weeks couple months here we've we've
talked a lot about the kind of the macro
environment and
since november really the bitcoin market
has has taken a big hit and a lot of the
stuff that we're looking at from a
market perspective um you know in terms
of bitcoin was actually quite healthy uh
we weren't seeing a huge distribution
happen we weren't seeing the traditional
kind of bear market uh you know the bear
market metrics that you see uh in terms
of on-chain what you're really seeing
was those kind of macro sellers right
because you had the fed kind of pivot
with inflation at 40-year highs
and really what you started to see was
the bond market started to croak and so
you saw your yields were selling off in
a big way rising which means that credit
was selling off and the equity market
took a downturn
as well and so i think just just
recently in the middle of february what
you saw was uh yields actually looked to
have at least momentarily topped and you
saw kind of a fed pivot with with this
next chart i have uh the fed funds uh
it's basically the fed funds futures um
so here's basically a prediction market
or futures market for for how many hikes
the fed's going to get in so we have it
for for march june september december
and you can kind of see a big reversal
in a lot of these uh in the middle of
february uh and at the same time
coincidentally uh you also saw the price
of bitcoin
bottom in a big way and so i think
that's that's the market walking back
how many hikes that the fed is going to
get in basically saying we're not going
to be as as tight with uh future
monetary policy and you know something
like bitcoin is going to react in a big
way to that yeah we obviously had those
rates come down a ton since uh since the
pandemic started in early 2020 but then
you have a chart talking about the
target fed fund rates um can you just
talk about what you mean here
yeah so this is basically uh this next
chart is showing uh this dynamic uh in
there are you talking about the chart we
just showed or the next one the next
chart the next one the uh the target
yeah so this is for the march meeting
and basically uh this is the market's
probability of of uh how many rate hikes
were gonna come in march in real time so
you see basically uh until like uh what
was it like january or february there
was like the market was giving no chance
for the fed to hike whatsoever
twice so two rate hikes would be a 50
basis point rate hike and all of a
sudden in february uh you what you saw
was that probability blew out to 94
93.75 percent uh and this chart actually
put it up yesterday the market's now
giving the fed us a five percent
probability of two hikes and basically
95 chance of only one height and so what
we saw was kind of this peak moment of
hawkishness and and equity markets
bitcoin cratered and and the volatility
across asset classes really blew out and
so we kind of see with this chart you
see that fed put almost in real time
it's quite remarkable and i think it
just kind of speaks to to where we are
in terms of uh the you know the
macroeconomic environment yeah and it's
giving it a zero percent chance for no
rate hike
yeah i mean
we'll see about that i think the fed's
kind of cornered uh politically and so
uh you know there's a lot of pressure on
them and 25 basis points it's it's not
that much when you think of inflation at
you know seven percent maybe maybe
higher with a lot of this kind of
geopolitical uncertainty uh happening
over in europe so we'll have to wait and
see but yeah i think i think more so
than anything that 25 basis point hike
is just kind of a symbolic thing that
hey
we're doing something here uh we're not
we're not letting this thing uh just
completely run on its own gotcha and
then bitcoin is obviously a very um
volatile asset but it looks like the s p
is also pretty volatile uh based on what
you're showing here can you talk about
this s p and then the volatility index
yeah so um we've we've talked a lot
about um the vix which is this
volatility index and it's kind of a
sentiment or a gauge of risk off in
markets and so you saw in march of 2020
this this volatility index really blew
out and it was at the same time if you
overlay the bitcoin chart uh when the
vix you know really really went to like
80. it was the same time that bitcoin
created like 50 in just a matter of days
or even in the same day and so what we
see here is uh we're kind of now
entering this regime of higher
volatility uh in general for for equity
markets and so if you overlay this on on
shorter time frames with the bitcoin
price you saw that the local bottom uh
in 2022 was when the vix hit 38 so it
was like that local high in the vix was
the local bottom for bitcoin and as that
volatility came back in lowered a little
bit uh bitcoin recovered the s p
recovered and so i think we're in this
regime of of higher volatility in
general uh for equities and so
i i would expect the volatility to
remain there for bitcoin as well
but it just kind of shows uh you know
how shaky things are with with this kind
of regime of high high inflation low
yields and credit markets are kind of
gurgling under the surface are you
looking to see that volatility be
um be correlated in the future as well
or do you think that's kind of like a
one-off instance with bitcoin and the s
p
yeah i think uh it's just kind of this
this really shows or i guess quantifies
kind of uh the risk on risk-off
sentiment and really if anything uh i
think the one of the bigger reasons why
bitcoin bottom first is you have kind of
two types of allocators in this asset
class i mean more than that but
generally speaking you have the kind of
crypto natives bitcoin native adopters
that that aren't aren't trading uh based
on
you know volatility in equity markets or
credit markets and they're just adopting
bitcoin as a monetary asset um and maybe
increasingly so as kind of um something
to use as as capital flight or two to i
mean people will get upset with me
saying this but as a way to avoid
sanctions or maybe in canada as a way
you know to not be deep platform from
the financial system bitcoin is kind of
just this tool that anybody can use in
this kind of neutral way so you have
those type of of uh allocators per se
and you also have just you know the
macro traders right and so as we saw
basically two two three four months of
of downtrend bitcoin markets equity
markets sold off in a big way i think a
lot of those macro allocators if you
want to call them that uh sold off their
coins they sold off their holdings uh
and so the crypto natives kind of
stepped in in a big way and we saw
that's why we saw this momentarily the
coupling but uh in the future i expect
you know that correlation will remain at
least to an extent because kind of
everything especially bitcoin equities
is a function of this like central bank
liquidity tied um and if they you know
if the tide pulls back bitcoin's gonna
gonna struggle to do great even though i
think our performance is is still my
base case over a longer term time
horizon so i expect the correlation to
remain but i think you know what really
defines bitcoin is these momentary
periods of huge outperformance where a
lot of your returns will be made
gotcha yeah so those returns will be in
like short bursts and then we have
another chart talking about the bitcoin
supply and what has moved in the last
three months can you uh can you talk
about this chart
yeah so you know throughout this this
drawdown we've we've highlighted um you
know i have on on the show as well as
just kind of in general um highlighted
how strong the on-chain side of things
were uh in terms of of bitcoin uh supply
and just how really we hadn't really
seen the demand side come in so so if
and when those macro tides turned which
we've seen a little bit i don't know if
we're out of the woods yet in terms of
macroeconomic geopolitical uncertainty
but if and when those kind of tides turn
in terms of marginal sellers becoming
marginal buyers what we'll really see is
is a big outperformance and so what
we're seeing here is the percent of
supply bitcoin supply that circulating
supply that's moved within the last
three months is near all-time lows it's
not quite at all time lows but it's just
there and so we kind of had this really
really small free float of bitcoin out
there that are being traded that are
available uh on the market and so this
is just kind of showing just you know
we're in quite rare error this is far
from what a top looks like and you can
definitely see that from the price
action itself
but really this is just kind of showing
how squeezy uh the market kind of kind
of can be and so i think this is one of
the things that we've been showing uh
but i kind of love this chart just to
show you know how prime the bitcoin
market is to explode higher if we see
those you know marginal buyers return in
a big way and we just started to see
that yesterday in my opinion would you
expected a bigger move uh percent wise
of coins given what's happened
internationally in the last month or so
or is this kind of right on target
yeah i mean i think really what this is
showing is just like kind of that
convicted hobbler base uh just
continuing to to you know scoop up those
coins uh especially you know we saw
these really low figures throughout much
of 2020 we saw somewhat of a
distribution into 2021 as bitcoin went
parabolic and since then we've seen a
reaccumulation with a slight deviation
of trend uh with somewhat of this macro
uncertainty but i think really you know
the the exciting thing is that we have a
potentially a bunch of new allocators
into this asset uh with all the stuff
happening geopolitically um from kind of
like a almost like a risk off uh
standpoint where you know sovereign debt
has become a lot more risky we have
sanction risk credit risk all of this
stuff happening um you know there's 150
million people in russia and and you
really have to feel for them because
there's an autocratic dictator doing all
this stuff that that they probably have
you know want nothing to do with and
their currency devalued by 50 overnight
their stock market crashed by 50
overnight and they're basically shut off
from the global financial system so you
know it's it's i think it's somewhat a
little bit insensitive to be like hey
bitcoin fixes this bitcoin bitcoin
bitcoin when a bunch of people are
suffering and there's a war breaking out
but ultimately this this does highlight
the need and importance of this of a
global decentralized monetary system
that anybody can voluntarily opt into
right uh the censorship resistance of it
um you know russians that have nothing
to do with putin are you know being
punished because of this and so
i think there's there's a lot of new
allocators to this asset that you know
are gonna gonna enter uh in the next you
know in the coming weeks months years uh
that that haven't had exposure before
gotcha and then you have two charts here
talking about the btc alley perps um can
you just go ahead and talk about what
this chart means
yeah so part of the reason why bitcoin
you know we we talk about derivatives a
lot uh and there's you know we talk
about the macro we talk about on chain
and and really what makes these uh and
those two things matter a lot uh but
overlay that with with derivatives and
that's why you see these really
explosive moves there's a reason that
bitcoin will you know do nothing for a
couple days and then sometimes you know
it seemingly randomly explode 15
up in a day and a lot of that has to do
with how people are positioned in
derivative markets and so we have this
purpose funding rate which basically
which is basically uh you know this
derivative market is tethered to the
spot market is tracks the spot market
through this funding rate so if
derivatives are higher than spot price
what you're going to have is is long
positions are going to pay short
positions just to enter the market so it
really places a financial incentive to
keep this derivative market
close to that spot price and what with
this uh kind of uh
color scale this blue and red we see
when uh those that funding rate is
positive or negative and so recently you
kind of see that that negative or that
uh you know short bias not a short bias
but uh that negative funding rate
meaning longs were actually getting paid
to enter the market so we kind of saw
like a peak moment of of bearishness and
it and it's been worse in the past in
terms of the severity of how negative
the funding rate was but we kind of saw
just derived this market price in you
know worst case scenarios skew skew
bearish and and traditionally uh when
you get these kind of periods of
overextended bullishness or bearishness
uh bitcoin takes away max pain and
derivative markets and so we just saw
basically yesterday not only you know a
lot of spot allocators with some of this
geopolitical uncertainty but also a huge
short squeeze which is kind of why we
saw such such a massive move and all
that volatility yeah it seems like
everyone's trying to judge if we're in a
bearable market and people don't really
know what are your thoughts on are we in
a bear market a bull market are we
neutral right now
yeah i mean you know there's a lot of
technical definitions in wall street
it's 20 off of highs as a is a bear
market and so we've and wall street's
definition we've been in a bear market
for a while but i think we're kind of uh
in a in a secular bowl and people may
say you know a couple weeks ago how are
we in a bull market 50 you know closer
to 60 off the highs
and i i really just think uh those that
traditional four-year cycle that a lot
of people think about of of parabolic
boom and then 80 bust um that's that
kind of mental model may be a little bit
obsolete and not saying we can't draw
down 80 or go parabolic again
but just you know the profile of bitcoin
the liquidity profile uh of bitcoin the
asset has has changed and that there's
no doubt about that and so you know
you're seeing a lot of people basically
use it as a check on the fed it's kind
of like a a signal of of central bank
your responsibility and that's kind of
what i was trying to display in the
first couple slides so to put a bowl or
bare label on it it's pretty tough and i
think you know there's some there's some
headwinds uh with the macro environment
that you know bitcoin could just chop
around here a little bit uh but it is it
is very telling to see this massive
decoupling and i know uh personally
there's a lot of risk managers uh that
are watching the move over the last
couple days and and feeling like they
are they are fully underexposed and so i
think that's a catalyst for
potentially much higher prices over the
over the coming year yeah we saw we're
about 36 percent down from the all-time
high so by wall street's definition
we're definitely in a bear market
yeah um and maybe maybe something more
like 40 or 50 in bitcoin is more
appropriate so you know maybe maybe we
are technically maybe we aren't uh i
think more of a crab market where we're
chopping around a little bit is the
answer and then does it matter how long
we actually stay down for um to be
considered in a bull market or a bear
market
uh yeah i mean i'm not not too sure
there i mean in terms of how how i'm
playing it i'm happy to accumulate um i
know you know
it's it's nothing but a thing like like
i've been saying and so yeah i'm sure i
know you pomp guys are feeling no
different uh it's just nothing but a
thing and i i don't really worry too
much about the technicalities of bowler
bear it's just you know it's just the
market gotcha gotcha yeah and then we
have another chart talking about kind of
the bitcoin price and then open interest
yeah so this is just kind of showing uh
that that uh short squeeze right so uh
we have open interest contracts and and
for for viewers uh they're for every
short there's a lot there can never be
more longs more shorts it's always equal
positioning so what do you what do you
see when bitcoin is pumping from say 42
uh to 44 000 like it did yesterday we
see how how underneath pain how open
interest tanks at the same time that
what that means and maybe they're
liquidations and maybe they're not i i
believe a lot of it was just shorts
closing out before their liquidation
price but open interest uh tanking as
bitcoins pumping means that
the move was shorts covering uh their
their positions and actually the open
interest was declining as a result so it
was people that sold their bitcoin uh
via derivatives sold sold bitcoin
derivatives and then had to cover as the
price was rising and so that was
basically a textbook short squeeze
yesterday so it's just kind of a visual
on what we're talking about in terms of
you know these derivative market
dislocations gotcha and then moving
forward how are you thinking about kind
of your bitcoin and what you're doing in
the market with your personal money is
it just still accumulating here or
yeah i mean uh you know i've been i've
been growing my bitcoin stack and a
little bit of a cash position for for a
while here um i for the most part i'm
always a buyer um and so while i do kind
of do a little bit more more stuff with
derivative market positioning than i
would probably advise for
the average person in terms of you know
just maybe sometimes shorter time frame
medium time frame uh positioning hedging
all that sort of thing uh you know i'm a
buyer every hour like i've said and i'll
happily do that at the highs i'll do
that at the lowest and everywhere in
between because i think bitcoin is the
best money the world's ever seen so you
know there's the trading aspect of it
there's the market analysis aspect of it
uh kind of you know asymmetric risk
award opportunities but longer term you
know there's there's nothing that can
compete with bitcoin as a monetary asset
and so in that sense it always makes
sense to be a buyer yeah green you and
myself as well i think we have the
advantage of being young um being able
to take that kind of long time horizon
instead of hey i need liquidity within
two years five years whatever it may be
uh with sailors quote because the best
time the best timeline for investing in
bitcoin is forever um and never selling
it so we'll see where the technology
goes and then
eight sleep is one of our sponsors here
what like crypto trades 24 7. so how has
your sleep changed over the last year or
two as you've gotten more into it
yeah i mean it's definitely
especially with with you know having
some maybe some positions trading all
that it definitely makes it fun
uh to you know never to never have an
off day uh trading 20 24 7 365 i mean
uh it definitely doesn't help probably
you know it'd be nice to have a have a
weekend off here but it makes it
exciting and uh you know so oftentimes
the biggest moves come from like a
saturday night or something crazy so uh
you know probably doesn't help my sleep
schedule to be honest with you gotcha
gotcha all right thanks dylan for
joining us i really appreciate it um we
also where do we send people to find you
on the internet
yeah you can just find me on twitter
dylan leclair underscore um
a lot of the charts i showed today are a
sneak peek or preview of the monthly
report we're dropping on wednesday uh so
check that out on the for the deep dive
you can find that in my the link in my
bio
so it's a letter that i produce with
bitcoin magazine covering kind of all
the stuff macro uh on chain analytics
bitcoin derivatives uh we like to kind
of put it all out there so i appreciate
you having me on and uh you know you're
killing it solo today man appreciate
that
catch you later